ich finde jede generation kann laut sein
und kann ihre interessen auch laut
artikuliere wir als grüne jugend und als
grüne möchten dafür kämpfen dass es
überhaupt nicht notwendig ist dass
gerade rentner innen und rentenpolitik
auch gegen junge generationen und
bildungspolitik ausgespielt wird
[Musik]
das werden sie sind auch noch nicht so
richtig alt 33 sind sie und sie sagen
aber es handelt sich bei den jungen um
eine generation selbstmitleid wir haben
sie ja gerade schon gehört erklären sie
es uns noch ein bisschen genau hier
vorstands generationen also die wohl
stenzel dass eine generation selbst
begleitet die so hohe abitur quoten hat
wie noch nie ich habe es noch mal
nachgucken uns hat 50 85 prozent eines
jahrgangs abitur gemacht ich habe in
hamburg 54 prozent in beiden sind 32
irgendwo dazwischen
die sammeln auslandserfahrungen die
wachsenden super aus die sagen so auch
die zukunft wird ganz furchtbar hingeht
so gut seitdem geht es zu gut und ich
war letzte woche in babenhausen einer
shisha bar die vom rapper haftbefehl
betrieben wird und haben damit den
jungen leuten geredet das sind
vielfältig einwanderer kinder die mir
erzählte um ihre eltern sind aus dem
kosovo gekommen und haben eine kuh
verkauft um nach deutschland zu kommen
und die ja man nicht die haben alle eine
ausbildung gemacht die sagen es gibt
probleme und die pandemie war nicht
leicht aber die sagen ich schaffe das
und ich kann mich einbringen und das
finde ich tragisch in die dänen zu gut
geht dann sagen nee das ist schwierig
und die die es eigentlich schwer haben
sagen wir schaffen das jetzt auch um das
thema gerechtigkeit innerhalb einer
generation tun ja wir geben das mal auf
deine seite auf die andere seite an das
leider erst zusagen die wir gerade auch
schon im film kennen gelernt haben frau
schlottmann herzlich willkommen
danke fürs kommen
verschwinden sitzt ihnen direkt
gegenüber auf der anderen seite sie
haben gerade seine meinung gehört teilen
sie das
ich glaube nicht dass das problem die
jungen menschen sind es gibt unzählige
menschen die auf die straße gehen die
sich einbringen die soziale initiativen
gründen und starten allein über project
haben in den letzten jahren mit
zehntausenden von jungen menschen
gearbeitet die soziale initiativen
gestartet haben ich glaube das problem
ist dass wir neue orte formate kanäle
möglichkeiten brauchen wie dieser
ideenreichtum den es auch in der breite
gibt wird er auch in die breite kommen
kann
und genau da brauchen wir den
konstruktiven dialog zwischen politik
zwischen bestehenden institutionen und
die umsetzungskraft auch dieser
bestehenden institution aber ich glaube
nicht dass wir die transformation der
nächsten jahre bewältigen können wenn
wir diese ideen nicht einbinden und
unter anderem machen über patrick gerber
gerade ein programm das nennt sich an
genau 400 junge menschen fördern die die
genau das tun sie bekommen für ein
halbes jahr lebenshaltungskosten von uns
gezahlt und entwickeln neue kanäle
formate ideen wie sie sich auch
einbringen können und wie die stimme von
jungen menschen wieder mehr gehört wird
also es gibt diese jungen menschen also
lasst sie uns fördern und mit ihnen
arbeiten und sprechen und vor allen
dingen lassen sie uns mit den jungen
menschen sprechen und ich nur über sie
wir haben ja auch welche bei uns im
publikum frau kasper herzlich willkommen
ob ihm
guten abend
sind sie ich sag jetzt mal sehr pauschal
und frech sind sie die generation
selbstmitleid ich finde nicht ich finde
gerade in dem moment wo man sich
beschwert oder wenn es bemitleiden
dann zeigen wir doch auf wo konflikte
sind wo fehler sind und dass man da was
machen muss ich sehe wie ganz viele
leute nach mallorca fliegen aber ich
habe meine unicom von innen gesehen
er muss was getan werden und es ist
wichtig wenn wir nicht sagen würden wenn
wir jetzt still sitzen würde da erst gar
nicht hier wären dann würde es keine
veränderung geben und das ist finde ich
gerade wichtig dann springen wir wieder
auf die andere seite unsere sendung
heißt ja zdf duelle für und wider genau
und ich stehe hier auf der anderen seite
und begrüße peter wolf bei uns in der
sendung herzlich willkommen
als diese rentner sie haben jetzt dass
ich sage mal klagen der jüngeren gehört
die haben das gefühl sind so ein
bisschen hinten runtergefallen vor allem
während der pandemie können sie das
verstehen und würden sie nicht auch
sagen dass ihre generation ein bisschen
bevorzugt wurde
na ja das muss ich nicht so sehen okay
aber ich kann verstehen die jungen
generation kann ich verstehen
sie hat viel mitgemacht viel ausgelassen
ich habe öfter diese schüler oder
jugendlichen gehört in den medien
geklagt hat im bild ein ganzes jahr also
keine disco kein sport und so weiter von
der schule waren und ganz abgesehen
oder muss ich sagen dieses jahr fehlt
mir ja auch ja ich wohne in einer
altersgerechten wohnanlage der
sozialstiftung köpenick fühle mich dort
sehr wohl aber mir fehlt ja auch
konzerte die ich gerne besucht hätte
eine reise
das hörte mir auch und muss ich aber
sagen im unterschied der junge mensch
der hat noch seine 60 oder 70 jahre vor
sich
sie sollte ja nutzen ich habe noch sechs
oder sieben jahre vor mir gut geht so
und nun muss ich mal sagen 60 zu 67 zu
600 jungen vater einzuziehen und diese
haben vergessen dafür immer höher
das einfach mal zurück in die mitte und
frage einfach frau peters was sagen sie
einem rentner wie herrn wolf und was
handeln
die grünen und sie als junge vertreterin
der grünen was haben sie denn den alten
zu bieten
ich glaube wir müssen erstmal auch damit
auch um zu sagen das ist ein
generationenkonflikt ist was corona
hervorgebracht hat ich glaube dass
corinna vor allem gezeigt hat ist dass
es eine soziale krise ist und dass wir
probleme in allen generationen haben die
wir bekämpfen müssen und dass es ihnen
natürlich wenn sie ihren sport in der
anlage machen nicht mehr machen konnten
wenn sie vielleicht nicht ihre freunde
treffen konnten genauso schlecht ging
wie uns die wir nicht mehr zur uni gehen
konnten ich habe auch im sommer von
corinna meinen master studium angefangen
und ich war noch kein einziges mal in
der uni also wir alle haben unsere
geschichten zu erzählen was wir alles
nicht mehr gesehen haben nichts dazu
trotz müssen wir glaube ich den menschen
zurück in den mittelpunkt stellen und
müssen wir anfangen politik nicht immer
nur anhand von wirtschaftswachstum
wirtschaftszahlen oder auch ja ausfällen
in der wirtschaft machen sondern müssen
wir gucken wie wir zusammen mit ihnen
und wie wir als junge menschen zusammen
eine bessere und lebenswertere politik
für alle machen können das heißt ich
möchte dafür kämpfen und wir als grüne
jugend und als grüne möchten dafür
kämpfen dass es überhaupt nicht
notwendig ist dass gerade rentner innen
und rentenpolitik auch gegen junge
generationen und bildungspolitik
ausgespielt wird sondern dass wir eine
neues rentensystem schaffen dass
einerseits ihn erwirkt sich eine gute
rente zu haben dass auch ermöglicht in
würde zu altern oder vor allem dass auch
generationenübergreifende projekte
möglich macht wo wir auch
generationenübergreifend voneinander
lernen können
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir eben auch
und das ist das soziale daran uns als
junge generation stärken und auch müssen
wir in arbeitsmarktpolitik gucken wie es
nicht dazu
dazu kommt dass am ende so viele
menschen so viele frauen auch in
altersarmut das was sie ja sagen ist man
muss eigentlich politik machen können
für jung und alt ohne sie gegeneinander
auszuspielen sondern im grunde alle auch
mitdenken das muss ja eigentlich immer
der anspruch von politik sein sollte es
jedenfalls herr mohring
aber wenn man so die stimmen der jungen
zusammen fast hat man schon den eindruck
dass da das gefühl ist wer wählt
erzählt und wir werden einfach nicht
gehört hätten sich die jungen leute
vielleicht lauter anders äußern müssen
damit sie sie hören ja ich glaube schon
ist eine möglichkeit
ich habe letzte woche mit der jungen
leuten gesprochen von freier software
wir sind jetzt nicht so nah bei uns es
war ein spannendes gespräch weil ich
wissen wollte was denken diese jungen
leute tatsächlich was haben sie vor
erwartungen an politik an mich wenn ich
in den bundestag einziehen sollte im
september
was kann ich beitragen um sachen auch
diese forderung auch zuhören oder auch
in politische überlegungen auch
einzubeziehen
und ich habe denen gesagt es ist gut
dass ich engagiert ich erwarte den
letzten wochen auch zu laut so leise bei
natürlich durch die pandemie aber wenn
man sich gemeinsam sollen ja auf die
straße gehen und demonstrieren clan hat
man eine andere diskussion einer
pandemie
ich hab da gerade gesagt wo die auflagen
sind ging es ja jetzt nicht jetzt gehts
weiter
und das müssen wir nutzen ich finde jede
generation kann laut sein und kann ihre
interessen auch laut artikulieren
da bin ich noch einmal frau peters
erwarten ziehen sie sich dann den schuh
an ihre generation war nicht laut genug
wären wir nicht sagen dass wir nicht
laut genug waren ich erwarte auch
ehrlich gesagt noch antworten auch von
ihrer partei wo wir auch briefe zum
beispiel an bildungsministerin
carlitscheck geschrieben haben und das
als jugendorganisation auch zusammen mit
der jungen union also ihrer
jugendorganisation und bis heute 16
monate danach keine antwort bekommen hat
also ich glaube artikulation alleine
reicht nicht sondern dürfen absolut sein
wenn einer was sagt dass man ja gleich
sagt nee das stimmt nicht falsch egal
ich hab da nicht gesagt das ist die
einzige antwort ist laut zu sein es war
auf die frage was wird wir machen ich
finde dass es gut wäre wenn die junge
generation laut es gibt auch leute die
wollen das gar nicht die können sich gar
nicht so laut sie kreieren die wollen
auch lieber zu hause sein wollen ihr
mädchen alleine kochen und wollen für
sich ihr leben mit ihrer damen genießen
tumor im rachen das ist wichtig lassen
sie uns noch mal auf diese seite gehen
und noch mal eine stimme von hast du
sagen darf den älteren semestern hier
einheitlich begrüßte rolf specht
herzlich willkommen
das sommertraining sie betreiben wäre
alten und pflegeheime denken sie denn
dass die ältere generation eine stärkere
lobby hat bei der politik nicht
unbedingt man sieht den älteren
natürlich als wähler aber ich möchte
auch mal appellieren an die ältere
generation von früher mein vater als
junger mann war sieben jahre in
gefangenschaft den sind sieben jahre
verloren gegangen hat nichts dafür
gekriegt 1000 dem a-kader gekriegt für
sieben jahre und ich muss alle waren die
politik appellieren wir müssen mehr geld
ausgeben für junge menschen und für alte
menschen
alte menschen die kriegsgeneration im
pflegeheim lebensmittel und getränke
können wir investieren in pflege am fünf
euro am tag
ich finde es eine unverschämtheit für so
ein reiches land hermann ersparen kauft
man eben masken für eine milliarde für
eine milliarde nicht brauchbar sind
herr scheuer gibt eine milliarde und
mehr aus für die mautgebühr herr maas
verteilt milliarden in der ganzen welt
ich denke die politik muss an die
eigenen wähler denken und auch für die
bürger etwas und wenn ich sie haben auch
der standort wollen sie auch nicht die
generationen gegeneinander ausspielt
nein denn ich darüber nochmal nachfragen
dass das was sie gesagt haben ist ja die
politik soll an die wähler denken
hamburger noch einmal nachgefragt mit
diesem lauter ich glaube das treibt auch
die die jungen leute um ich komme mir
vorstellen der eine oder andere art mit
hier gerade seine wut weg sie sind ja
volksvertreter muss man wirklich auf die
straße gehen muss man ein lobbyverband
gründen damit sie sie hören nein
natürlich nicht
ein guter politiker gehört auch ein city
problem mit in seinem land da sind es
ist darum ein wechsel ist es dann beim
wechselseitiges geht nehme der
gesellschaft sich zu engagieren für eine
kurze zeit für ein projekt für die idee
zu hause in der gemeinde oder fürs ganze
land das ist doch nicht verboten das zu
machen das macht doch unser land ist
stark und vital wenn man sich selber
einbringt ob man das in der partei macht
oder einem verein
meine sorge ist vielmehr nach der
pandemie dass sie nicht eine frage von
generationskonflikten haben sondern wie
es unserer gesellschaft auseinander
gedriftet finden wir wieder zusammen
ich finde die größte aufgabe die neue
politik haben muss nach der
bundestagswahl ist wie hält sie dieses
land zusammen wie verbinden wir uns
wieder weil ganz viele leute haben da
auch sozusagen in dem ein anderthalb
jahren es auch ferland sich zu
engagieren vielleicht eher ruhig verein
sind weniger mitglieder in den vereinen
sind keine leute mehr gegangen weil es
keine programme mehr gibt wenn viele
haben sich sozusagen entwöhnt und wenn
wir nicht alle hassen kaum junge
generation und gucken wir haben
nämlich was vorbereiten wir denken
vielleicht ist es auch ein
repräsentations problem wird ein kleines
quiz mit ihnen machen frau peters wie
was meinen sie ist der
altersdurchschnitt der grünen
bundestagsfraktion
wissen sie raten mit einer zahl 48
humorigen cdu-bundestagsfraktion 55 55
geblendet dass mal kurz ein bei der cdu
sind es 54 jahre bei den grünen sind es
51 und der bundesdurchschnitt beträgt
44,5 das heißt die jungen sind
unterrepräsentiert im bundestag ist das
ein grund warum vielleicht manchmal die
bedürfnisse der jungen generation ein
bisschen hinten runterfallen
es kann ein grund sein aber ich würde es
nicht als alleinigen grund nennen
ich würde auch sagen dass ein älteres
semester auch in der
grünen-bundestagsfraktion genauso gut
politik für junge leute machen kann und
gegen die klimakrise kämpfen kann
für bessere bildungspolitik also würde
ich nicht alles nur am alter definieren
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir auch aus
dieser statistik gelernt und werden
jetzt als grüne jugend mit zu vielen
bundestags kandidierenden kandidieren
haben schon gute listenplätze bekommen
und werden mit so einem tollen team wie
noch nie unter 28 jährige in den
nächsten bundestag bringen
[Musik]